j'ai dit moi je crois je pense que ma
femme est devenue sourde ah bah l'autre
j'ai dit attends je vais te donner un
tuyau tu sais ce que tu fais que tu
rentres ce soir tu dis à haute voix
chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange toi si elle
te répond pas tu progresses dans la
maison tu vas dans la pièce où se trouve
ta femme carrément la cuisine par
exemple tu rentres dans la cuisine et là
tu redis à haute voix chérie casse qu'on
mange toi si elle répond toujours pas
tu viens derrière elle 50 cm derrière
elle tu mets tes mains comme ça et tu
dis chalet
cash qu'on mange et si elle répond pas
c'est qu'elle est sourde mec il dit
d'accord il rentre franchit la porte
qu'est-ce qu'on mange rien dans la
cuisine et ce moment il va derrière sa
femme qu'est-ce qu'on mange et là sa
femme elle se retourne et elle lui dit
pour la troisième fois des lasagnes
[Applaudissements]